>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD, FORMER
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE MARK ESPER
WHO WAS FIRED VIA TWEET JUST
DAYS AFTER FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP LOST THE 2020 ELECTION, IS
SUING THE CURRENT DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT.
THE LAWSUIT WHICH WAS FIRST
REPORTED BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
IS OVER THE CURRENT PENTAGON'S
DEMAND THAT ESPER TAKE OUT,
QUOTE, SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF HIS
MEMOIR ABOUT HIS TIME AS
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
THE BOOK IS "A SACRED OATH."
IT'S SET TO BE RELEASED THIS
SPRING.
JOINING US IS FORMER DEFENSE
SECRETARY MARK ESPER IN HIS
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE FILING THE
LAWSUIT.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
WHAT DOES THE PENTAGON SEEM TO
BE SO WRD ABOUT THAT THEY WOULD
EDIT OUT OR BLOCK OUT, WHAT IS
IT, UP TO 60 PAGES?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, GOOD
AFTERNOON, JAKE.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
LET ME JUST SAY, THE -- MY VIEW
IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE A
FULL AND UNVARNISHED HISTORY OF
THE LAST PRESIDENCY THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHAT I AIM TO DO WAS TO
PROVIDE IMPORTANT INSIGHTS AND
ANECDOTES AND COLOR TO WHAT WAS
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE MOST
TUMULTUOUS SECOND HALVES OF AN
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY.
AND SO WHAT I DID WAS FOLLOW THE
LAW AND MY PERSONAL COMMITMENT
TO PROTECTING NATIONAL SECURITY
AND FILED MY MANUSCRIPT LAST MAY
FOR WHAT'S CALLED PREPUBLICATION
REVIEW.
I GOT THE DOCUMENT BACK NEARLY
SIX MONTHS LATER, AND THE REPORT
THAT I RECEIVED IN EARLY
OCTOBER, THE DOD TOLD ME THAT
ITEMS, MATERIAL ON NEARLY 60
PAGES WOULD NEED TO BE REDACTED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT DOD
DOESN'T DO ALL THE RETACTING.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD TO FARM IT
OUT, IF YOU WILL, TO AT LEAST A
DOZEN PLUS OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHO ALL IS
MARKING UP THE DOCUMENT BUT I'D
SAY THIS MUCH.
I SUBMITTED WHAT I BELIEVED AT
THE TIME AND STILL BELIEVE IS AN
UNCLASSIFIED MANUSCRIPT AND THAT
THE DODs AND OTHERS CONTINUED
REDACTIONS ARE ARBITRARY AND
UNFAIR.
AND THEY SHOULD RELENT AND ALLOW
THIS MANUSCRIPT TO BE PUBLISHED
AS I WROTE IT.
>> THE LAWSUIT, YOUR LAWSUIT
CITES, QUOTE, SIGNIFICANT TEXT
IS BEING IMPROPERLY WITHHELD
FROM PUBLIIGATION UNDER THE
GUISE OF CLASSIFICATION.
THE WITHHELD TEXT IS CRUCIAL TO
TELLING IMPORTANT STORIES
DISCUSSED IN THE MATERIAL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THEY
ARE REDACTING?
HOW MUCH OF IT IS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ACTIONS?
HOW MUCH OF IT IS ABOUT CHINA OR
UKRAINE OR RUSSIA?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
REDACTING BECAUSE THEY GIVE YOU
FEEDBACK AS TO WHAT IT IS.
WHAT I DON'T KNOW IS WHY.
AND I ALSO -- THE CLEAR REASONS
WHY.
AND THE PEOPLE I'VE TALKED TO AT
DOD HAVE BEEN REDUCTANT TO STATE
IT IS CLASSIFIED.
I OFTEN GET THESE ARE SENSITIVE
ITEMS THAT MIGHT AFFECT
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS, THAT
ARE SENSITIVE.
THEY'VE ASKED ME TO EXCLUDE
QUOTES TO EXCLUDE CONVERSATIONS
WITH FOREIGN LEADERS.
YOU KNOW, I TRIED TO WORK WITH
DOD INFORMINALLY BETWEEN THE
TIME THAT I RECEIVED MY FIRST
RESULTS BACK FROM THE REVIEW AND
OVER A MONTH-LONG PERIOD WHICH
ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN ME HAVING
TO WRITE A PERSONAL LETTER TO
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AUSTIN.
I TRIED TO WORK INFORMALLY.
THEY WERE TELLING ME WERE HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED ITEMS.
I'D GO BACK ONLINE AND FIND THE
DOD REPORTED THE MATERIAL
THEMSELVES.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE REASON
IS BUT AGAIN IT'S ARBITRARY.
IT'S CAPRICIOUS AND JUST DOES
INJUSTICE TO THIS IMPORTANT PART
OF AMERICA'S HISTORY THAT THE
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT.
AND NEED TO UNDERSTAND IN DEPTH.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M COMMITTED TO
GETTING TO THE END OF THIS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE PUBLISH THE
MANUSCRIPT IN FULL SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE FULL
STORY OF WHAT HAPPENED, THE GOOD
AND THE BAD DURING THOSE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NOT WANTING
TO -- YOU TO REPORT FAVORABLY ON
ANYTHING YOU THINK TRUMP DID
RIGHT?
DO YOU THINK THERE IS POLITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS AT PLAY HERE?
OH, WE DON'T WANT ESPER TO
INSULT WORLD LEADER TWO BECAUSE
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO DEAL WITH
HIM?
OR DO YOU THINK THIS IS JUST A
BUREAUCRATS BUREAUCRATIC?
>> I THINK IT'S A COMBINATION OF
BUREAUCRACY, MAYBE LAZINESS ON
THE PART OF THE REVIEWERS.
ALSO, I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
THERE ARE FOLKS IN THE POLICY
WORLD, AT LEAST AT OSD POLICY,
MAYBE OTHER -- MAYBE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS
AND THE DIPLOMACY OF IT ALL.
BUT THIS IS VERY SIMPLE.
I HAVE A LAWSUIT PENDING.
I CAN'T GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL.
IF THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS,
IF THE ADMINISTRATION SHARES MY
VIEW WE SHOULD HAVE TRANSPARENCY
IN GOVERNMENT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT COMPROMISING
NATIONAL SECURITY, WHICH I
REMAIN CONVINCED I HAVE NOT DONE
NOR WILL I EVER DO, THEN THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND I THINK IT
REALLY LIES AT THE WHITE HOUSE
NOW BECAUSE THIS EXTENDS BEYOND
DOD TO MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS.
THE WHITE HOUSE CAN SIMPLY COME
DOWN AND SAY, LOOK, IF IT'S
CLASSIFIED, LET SECRETARY ESPER
KNOW.
ALLOW HIM TO REVIEW IT.
I RETAIN MY CLEAR ARNSS.
IF NOT, THEN REMOVE THE
REDACTIONS AND ALLOW HIM TO MOVE
FORWARD AND PUBLISH THIS BOOK AS
WRITTEN.
>> MIGHT YOU JUST DO WHAT JOHN
BOLTON DID AND JUST PUBLISH IT
AND LET THE CHIPS FALL WHERE
THEY MAY KNOWING GOVERNMENT
SUITS LIKE THIS WHEN THEY ARE AS
WEAK AS YOU DESCRIBE THIS ONE,
ULTIMATELY FAIL?
>> WELL, I COULD, BUT, LOOK, I
WANT TO DO IT THE RIGHT WAY, SET
THE PROPER EXAMPLE.
I FOLLOWED THE PROCESS
DILIGENTLY FOR SIX MONTHS.
I'VE ENGAGED WITH THEM FORMALLY
AND INFORMALLY AND THE NEXT STEP
HAS BEEN THE LAWSUIT STEP.
THAT SAID, I WOULD SAY THE WHITE
HOUSE CAN COME IN, STEP IN AND
SAY ALLOW IT TO MOVE FORWARD AND
GO FROM THERE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'LL TAKE THIS ONE DAY AT A
TIME.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEIR
HISTORY, OUR HISTORY AND WHAT IT
MEANS BECAUSE I'VE WROTE THIS
MEMOIR FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
NOT JUST TO TELL A GOOD STORY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED DURING THOSE
TUMULTUOUS TIMES BUT ALSO FOR
HISTORY, FOR STUDENTS OF
GOVERNMENT.
FOR POLICYMAKERS TODAY.
TO GIVE THEM SOME INSIGHTS INTO
WHAT I WAS THINKING.
HOW I TRIED TO WORK MAY WAY
THROUGH DAY-TO-DAY ACTIVITIES.
WHAT WERE THE CORE PRINCIPLES
THAT GUIDED ME?
WHERE DID I SUCCEED?
WHERE DID I COME UP SHORT?
I THINK THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT I THINK PEOPLE WILL
FIND VERY INTERESTING WHEN THEY
READ MY MEMOIR, "A SACRED OATH."
>> I KNOW YOU WEREN'T SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE DURING THE
INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6th.
BUT HAS THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE REACHED OUT TO YOU TO
TALK TO YOU?
JUST WONDERING AS LONG AS I HAVE
YOU HERE?
>> YES, THEY HAVE REACHED OUT TO
ME.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO CONNECT
YET.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I WASN'T THERE AT THE TIME.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE, TRAGIC EVENT
AND OBVIOUSLY STRUCK ALL OF US
PRETTY DEEPLY.
BUT WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES.
I DID NOT FOCUS ON THAT.
I TRIED TO FOCUS ON MY TENURE AS
BOTH SECRETARY OF THE ARMY,
WHERE I THINK WE MADE VERY
IMPORTANT STRIDES IN TERMS OF
MODERNIZING THE UNITED STATES
ARMY AND THEN, OF COURSE, MY 18
MONTHS AS SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
WHERE AGAIN I COVERED THE MOST
CONTROVE